i'm sorry did you say something i was
listening to something on these new
apple airpods yes it's true the new
iphone 7 does not have a headphone jack
but that's actually not the biggest news
of the event
i got to spend some time with the iphone
7 and 7 plus apple may say the design is
brand new but that's not really true
what is great about these new designs is
the water resistance
you can't go swimming with it but if you
drop it in a toilet you should be safe
the cameras on both phones are brand new
the smaller iphone has a 12 megapixel
camera with a new sensor and lens that
allow for brighter more detailed photos
and better low light shots the iphone 7
plus gets a bigger upgrade two 12
megapixel cameras used for real zooming
they'll also be able to add a depth
effect in an update this fall and you'll
definitely notice the brighter screen
yes rip headphone jack
you now plug headphones into the
lightning port apple's including a pair
of lightning earbuds in the box
and a dongle so you can plug in your old
ones or you can buy these air pods for
159
they also have some cool siri tricks
hey siri change the song the biggest
news of the iphone though may be battery
life apple is promising two more hours
on the 7 versus the 6s
of course i'll have to test that myself
the phones will start at 650
oh yeah there's also a new apple watch
the apple watch series 2 is water
resistant you can go swimming with it in
everything while the watch is still very
stylish it's very much focused on
fitness there's a brighter display and a
new dual core chip promising faster
performance and though it doesn't have a
cellular connection it has gps so you
can run or hike without your iphone the
series 2 watch will start at 370 dollars
and last year's watch drops to 270.
oh yeah that's it stay tuned for our
full reviews